what else do we have here mr neidorf
three plus two brilliant let's go for
this so let's allow mr neider to play
the niners ah he disconnected i'm afraid
i know he's back
okay fine
so how do we beat
how do we beat neither vincent neidorf
i don't know let's try my own trick
let's go bishop p2
and knight f5 here
this is a funny funny of bit lines that
uh
that i used to beat grishok in uh one of
the blitz games
so d5 is a move here i believe bishop a
5 is also fine
but at least then we get a play but d5
is a move
okay then we go bishop g5 now i think d4
is a move
so the point is that after yeah it
doesn't matter what's the point so
d4 is correct now after
g takes knight b1 it's a very sharp
position that is
maybe even better for white maybe not
but at least it's game so queen takes f6
was the main move
and now we just play so black has two
bishops and a very good pawn structure
but white has some
light squares and uh
uh some potential to attack to attack
the black king
this is ambitious
okay let's just castle just in case
rook jade wow
this is a really cool player okay let's
try to develop the pieces let's go 92
bishop c4 also looked reasonable
followed by queen h5 but
uh 92 looks even more solid to me
yeah this runs into bishop c4 followed
by
knight xe4
which once again is not the end of the
world obviously but at least we are
happy to see that
yeah this still allows knight xc4 queen
c4 knight f6
and knight xj check rook takes g2 is not
a drama at all so yeah i guess
we'll just take
he'll probably go 97 and play
but then yeah at least we have some
material
bishop is seven this looks really
strange
so we can just take on d4
there is nothing wrong with that i
believe
he plays bishop d7 so it's not that
ambitious after all he just tries to
finish the development being
being two pawns down already
what could we play here
queen d5 just leads to an ending that is
dead lost for black
is there something cool here okay queen
d5 is good enough actually
i mean i know this is not what you
expect but okay can i play just one
boring game in a row please
two extra pawns and an ending is uh good
enough
okay let's just take and now we are two
pawns up
with no compensation at all
yeah so now all the moves are decent so
b5 kind of makes sense but
uh yeah it allows him to castle after
castling we have f4 knight g4
bishop takes f7 yeah then he has some
control play maybe
we could also just play bishop e2 here
or bishop b3
i actually like bishop b3 for some
reason don't know why
rook g4 wow we are under attack
i'm scared okay can i play four please
somehow it turns out we will not be
checkmated
well never say never obviously but i
feel like we should survive this
overwhelming attack
yeah now we collect some okay
[Music]
okay thanks for the game short but tense
one